>>Student: There's
kids and there's a dog.
It is sunny, there is no fog.
There is a shadow--
>>Narrator: These fifth graders
are presenting poems they wrote
to acompany the digital
photographs they took.
>>Student: I'm gonna go online
because I'm researching my topic,
which is how to say "kite"
in different languages.
>>Narrator: In this
fifth grade class,
students are researching
and designing kites.
>>Going down all right.
>>Wow, that's-- that's a drop.
>>Narrator: And these sixth
graders are conducting experiments
to determine the heat of
fusion for various objects.
>>If it is melting at
ninety-three point five--
>>Narrator: These challenging
projects are part of a typical day
at Mott Hall, a fourth
through eighth grade science,
math and technology
magnet school in the heart
of New York's Harlem district.
>>Mirian: Traditionally, minority
students have not been encouraged
or inspired to go into
the professional fields
of mathematics, science
or technology.
So we feel that our mission
here at Mott Hall is really
to provide a very strong academic
foundation for these students
to go onto higher learning.
>>Student: Matter exists
in different phases,
three of these are
solid, liquid and gas.
The other two are Bose-Einstein
condensate and plasma,
but these two are not
common on this planet.
>>Narrator: In nineteen
ninety-five, the school participated
in a pilot program that eventually
provided laptop computers
to every teacher and student.
>>Mirian: And when we put the
laptops and the technology directly
into the hands of teachers and
students, we started to move
from a more traditional instructional
model to a project based
and constructivist model,
and we really embrace this
as a school community, because
we feel that what is important
for our students is for
them to be directors
and managers of their own learning.
>>What kind of poem would
you make out of that one?
>>A silly one.
>>Mirian: We really wanted to have
children collaborate with each other,
have children engaged in
multidisciplinary types of projects
that were longer, that
were more complex.
>>What's the temperature
of the water?
>>The water, measure the temperature.
>>Mirian: We feel this
is more authentic,
we feel this is more challenging work
for our students, and we have seen
that it had yielded very
positive results for our students.
>>Student: Using the graph
paper on the compouter,
I've created a scale for my kite.
>>Sandra: At this point in math,
we're studying ratio and proportion
and they're difficult concepts,
especially for a ten year old.
>>Narrator: For teachers like
Sandra Skea, who teaches math,
science and social studies, the most
successful projects cover the whole
curriculum and involve
new technologies.
>>Sandra: For this
project, the laptops proved
to be especially useful in
creating the scale drawings,
in doing the research, and
be able to make revisions,
in order that they could
set up ratio and proportion
and see instantly what
the effects were.
We have the wireless, so it
was easy for us to go online,
get additional information.
It's going to make the whole idea
of creating our website easy,
because we've got most
of the work already done
and it's just formatting it
and shooting it up to the net.
>>Narrator: Skea believes projects
bring out the best in her students.
She was particularly impressed with
the progress of one of her students
who wrote a story about
Ben Franklin's kite.
>>Student: He was going to make
me get shocked by the lightning.
"No," I screamed, without
saying a word.
He took me outside and
flew me in the air.
I flew rapidly through the
sky, hoping not to get struck.
Then Ben screamed, "Make me proud!"
>>Sandra: Once he became
involved with projects,
his interest in school really grew,
and all his potential just
evolved, it just exploded.
And now he consistently does is
work and has consistently done well,
and he's no longer afraid to use
his imagination, to take risks,
to try new things and I credit
a lot of that to the projects
that he's been able
to get involved with.
>>Narrator: At Mott Hall,
the learning does not
stop when classes end.
After school offerings
include tai chi and chess.
>>Jerald: Chess does
a lot for young people
and I think the most important thing,
it makes them responsible
for their decisions.
Every move has a consequence, and you
can see from the first year of chess,
kids being a lot more
aware of the moves they do.
>>Narrator: Practice like this
has helped make Mott Hall national
chess champioins.
It also dovetails neatly with the
school's educational philosophy.
>>Jerald: I'm not even
really interested always
in the right answer.
If they come up with the
right answer, that's great,
but I'm interested
in the investigation.
Again, that interior dialog, "Well,
what were you thinking about?"
>>Did you have some growth or no?
>>Mm, yeah, it was decreasing.
>>Narrator: The school has
also formed partnerships
with nearby institutions like
City College of New York,
where these eighth
graders are working
on their class science project,
and advancing vital research
on single celled organisms.
>>Megan: When they first came, of
course, this was all completely new
to them, so they didn't
know about foraminifera,
not that I'd expect them to.
They didn't know about
dinoflagellates,
not that I would expect them to.
They were interested though
in corollary ecosystems.
They decided on their own that they
wanted to do the light variation,
so I helped them, you know, set up
a sort of experimental protocol.
And then once I showed them how
to actually use the
instruments, it was amazing.
They just were able to do all
the counts, totally unsupervised,
and when they showed me their
board, I was really impressed,
because they had found
all sorts of pictures
and they put all the graphs together.
Their data tables, they
had everything lined up,
you know, absolutely perfectly.
>>Do you think it's time that
we transferred them again?
>>Transfer.
>>Definitely?
>>Susan: They'll talk to you about
these species of microorganisms just
as if they were the
scientists in the labs,
and that's exactly what we want,
for them to feel not necessarily
they're gonna become scientists,
but if that's what they
want to do, they can do it.
>>This one, right?
>>And that one.
>>Student: I think it's a
privilege to be here, and I found it
to be really fun, and it expanded
my horizons, like now I can see
that I have more choices for a job.
>>Megan: My experience
with this program has been
that project based learning
is absolutely essential,
because through the projects, the
students became more interested.
They took their own initiative.
Had this been from a
book or an article,
I don't believe that
would've happened.
>>Press collect.
>>Marc: It's not just
project learning.
It's really problem solving, it's
decision making, it's the opportunity
to present your ideas,
to evaluate your ideas.
There are rooms that
you can walk into
and it looks like chaos, you know.
It's rooms full of kids, moving
in all directions, sharing work,
but it's very productive.
It's productive noise, it's
noise of ideas being shared.
>>Sixty-six point five.
>>Marc: Of products being produced.
>>Let me see that.
>>Marc: There's an excitement
in that type of classroom.
Anyone who enters the
room is learning.
>>Whoa, from the seesaw, I
think it went up and down.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org